in what seems like a completely normal
university stairwell lurks a horror
beyond imagination the scp foundation an
organization devoted to capturing and
containing the supernatural refers to it
as
scp-087 but it's better known as the
endless staircase the endless staircase
is dark so dark that when you try to
illuminate it it seems to smother even
the brightest lights the deeper down you
go the sooner you realize that it just
seems to go on forever getting deeper
and deeper into the blackness below but
one thing worse than being alone on a
dark supernatural staircase is not being
alone on a dark supernatural staircase
people who've delved deep enough have
reported a horrifying face staring up at
them from below it's huge and pale with
no mouth and big white eyes without
pupils and this face does much more than
just the look studies by the scp
foundation have found that the face
begins to follow people back up the
stairs as they try to escape some have
gotten lucky often going mad from fear
in the years since others have never
been seen again